we're going rolling are we on are we on
with the legend Bryan Callen is busy
pretend pretend acting doing what he's
on the Goldbergs he is you know yours
can be on this week I am you know so
yeah acts like he's big-time so I said
that's fine you miss out I'm calling the
wrap the guest of the years back because
no co-host of the year goes well now she
did I'm a co always say Cyrus Odell hoes
so so since I've been gone
doing right get tweets all the time
people like gets to the Year guest the
air and I'm like come on come on come on
you could send them all so who's been
around lately that would be sort of a
guest of the year Kim's good I think I'm
back to back right and went back to bad
you're back to that champ Tony
Hinchcliffe was good never heard of him
[ __ ] that cool outfit who help me out
here who's Tony hit what's name ugly
Bobby Bobby [ __ ] Lee was the comedian
Bobby Lee hasn't been in a while I'm
eating so Cold Steve Austin was good he
be good you know you saw my show I bet
these I bet have some good stories don't
watch your P's and Q's around him too
what do you mean I mean Stone Cold
Stunner yes yeah the marina - yeah yeah
no no don't call I could see being good
I could see him being good if I ever
lost I don't think I will because I'm
kind of care to [ __ ] up today but if I
ever did lose guest beer to someone like
Stone Cold Steve Austin that'd be cool
but as far as like your your comedian
friends Kalin brings in here like oh
they don't count
no disrespect aquata more love all y'all
but you ain't gonna make my
[ __ ] belt
I'll [ __ ] at you better be doing you
better do be able to do a Stone Cold
Stunner in order to India yes you need
to take me now physically mentally and
emotionally yeah I feel like you're the
busiest guy I know you're literally
everywhere I was with my my family and
uh
well we're at the Grove and there's just
giant [ __ ] office shows through a
typical yeah Netflix you're watching it
no I haven't I've been busy bro did you
know you don't turn me off is you
talking all that [ __ ] about the big
three yeah good oh I didn't care the
[ __ ] down bro I'm not bugging Lorenzo
balls bad I will come down there and
[ __ ] you holy people are are you gonna
come down
with those [ __ ] blood of the same
around are you gonna wear these [ __ ]
boots down it yo I walk in Fighter it's
the fighter and a fruitcake talking to
sailor on skin take those [ __ ] glare
suck me wrong you're going oh uh Oh can
I come down I could jump down the
staples and [ __ ] you and Ice Cube up in
these boots look at these [ __ ] who
you got in your vim plain Hollywood too
long your Lorenzo's bald with his name's
Alonzo boss sponsible varney old he long
what what [ __ ] what rock of you with
nothing I'm like a big server what rock
have you been living underneath me I
would fall real sports
listen I only bought the real sports but
no don't hide the [ __ ] boots me
they're like can you look at how [ __ ]
touch the jeans on oh what'd I tell you
I said I was going to drag this
[ __ ] around his studio today yeah
we're done I'm gonna feel good right
this [ __ ] around here
Rojo do you all get into your talk about
all the success you come down the busted
ass Black Knight you have an attorney
but what do you believe
no no Kim is just no self-respecting
here's a [ __ ] where are you going to
a [ __ ] what are you doing with you
know I'm doing these are for Julio
Chavez the greatest bunch of all time
I've wore these for him you need go on a
horseback ride I don't know what Jeter
gave myself Duke
Khaleesi stuff [ __ ] Cletus I'm sure it's
Monday afternoon man takes a little
[ __ ] boots on bro where are you going
man I die my banner where we're dancing
they can't see your feet on esam see
them they can see you Doug so yo you
were you were - you're talking [ __ ]
about big three you didn't show up at
Staples I said come down here shoot some
bottom on come on job come on go down
there come the I know down there what's
gonna happen can you shoot some three I
guess I can I grew up playing basketball
pregnant I don't think you actually
[ __ ] didn't know you were another
guys I don't know Hollywood you [ __ ]
big strong guys you get in the [ __ ]
post you don't know jump up this way
from don't look that way this is the
problem with Hollywood Ewing town has
the same mistakes you guys all right why
would anybody nice cute so I walked over
Rondo ball Oh
been hard Oh Bieber that was all
relative down dar [ __ ] in the [ __ ] you
know anybody who loves celebrities more
than Brian can I sure though
you got a point that I mean he will suck
off a celebrity at the drop like he'll
just like run up like he'll do like a
James Brown slide a dick on his knee Oh
dick dive any time find the the
certified dick diver he's beautiful a
big indict he loves it he loves him but
you [ __ ] this is the crossover
kid man his crossover kid this is the
problem though you guys get twisted you
think I'm like Ice Cube we're gonna have
to have some fun you're not [ __ ]
nobody up nice yellow Ferrari I mean in
my water no I'm saying it real like
you're not putting anybody to sleep any
horn on a buddy night but it 101 you
were play 101 you put me 101 basketballs
you 111 sure rap wit but I know where
those [ __ ] shoes I couldn't still be
- yes but I probably won't up I put some
Kobe what's the [ __ ] do you're gon do
your real proper we go Brito proffers do
that Hollywood rather than therefore let
me see how you shoot well this should
just things like I shoot I did some
things you shoot like a shoe like this
let's see that give eye I don't see
elbow in elbow and I don't know I don't
I could just tell like how do you
dribble we go mom I got like I honorable
here I'm here baby spayed [ __ ]
that's another huh all right so first I
just want to say this
I'm so happy you're doing your thing I
was so I'm so happy that although it's
in it although although the things that
you're saying are disoriented and like I
really want to get you like I want to
get some scans and like full-body scans
like some CTE checks on you I think both
for you could argue that for both the
but I am so happy that you were doing
your thing on it with this whole fight
yeah and like you're the voice you know
it's not the voice of reason I think
it's the voice of [ __ ] retardation
about this fight you're doing so how
many bits do you have going on this
Conor McGregor fight really I just the
the bet I've in Vegas when the fight
first came out that Connor was gonna win
around or more and I bet that kind of
get a knock out okay you know I think I
got the the round or more I got at like
26 to 1 I put down 4 grand do the math
so
so the bet is what so it has to be on
the bots on the judges cards yeah Connor
ones are one round or more so plus one I
would take that bet
right it's boxing he not going to not
win one round in Vegas what all those
crazy fans but also think about boxing
with Floyd Mayweather he can easily win
the first round like the first round
go ahead guys the first few because I
think it the first the first few rounds
are going to be the most exciting me too
I think he's going to charge on a
percent and I think it can be awkward
and Floyd you have to download is moving
like what is this
right and then everyone's me watch at
home like damn who do you give that
round to shy Griffith Connor so how do
you want them at 4k that he'll win one
round or more so if if if he wins one
round or more at 4k how much you win
what's I got at 26 to 1 odds I one of my
very first Idol jinn what's the word the
past the aging I'm [ __ ] rich is how
much I don't know I'm [ __ ] rich I
know that I cook at 4,000 is that right
yeah well I put that for how do I get on
on that it's too late now because since
guys myself have been swinging the odds
pushing the audience now collars are
plus 552 you know to win the fight and
also good [ __ ] bad that's a good bit
but what's your other bet but other bet
is a dick pic with some money
that was some random dude I bet my
Salomon 100 I tried betting that
gentleman hundred grand and that why
ain't he turned it down
well that card went around or more and
now here here's here's what I'm gonna do
to you that's your boy man Internet now
check this out your boy Brandon is
choose your words - what's your what is
your what our toughest fight that you
were ever in it mmm and mmm a double
what's the toughest fight you've ever
been in probably crow cup okay and how
many rounds did it go three rounds and
who won I won okay
did he win any rounds yes okay do you
think that he's going around saying well
I won one round verse he's saying I lost
different why are you giving Conor
McGregor or participation prize for the
fight
if he wins one round if he wins to her
what's up what's the fight that you lost
what's your toughest fight who you're
like [ __ ] that was just like it was the
toughest loss that would like was like
the biggest disappointment
Bry Arlovski okay Tommy rousers at three
rounds three rounds I think I want
do you see route going all this that you
go you're not sitting there like you're
doing that now because you're breaking
up at the end of the day you're like
I'll aw I lost hundred percent so how
are you a real fighter a real ass kicker
giving Conor [ __ ] McGregor a
participation trophy the thing about the
MMA thing that's bothering me anything
about this fight amongst so many
different things and I know you probably
feel the same way about a lot of it is
that like even on text when we were
talking about coming in here and I've
read your tweets and I'm watching the
goddamn show like everybody else you
blown up top five podcasts I know it all
but you're sitting ago what if he wins
one round
it means this no it's a [ __ ] fight
now if he if he makes it through alive
and if cough what makes through a lot to
both gonna walk away rich and all that
[ __ ] but to sit there and qualify like
if he wins two rounds against Floyd may
wear with Floyd women are always going
to give a brown but no there's no boxer
that rarely goes 12 a know especially in
boxing when I noticed with but for MMA
fan service well if he wins two rounds
then he won and you know damn well
that'll say that bill rap I don't mean
in a reptile I'm it's yeah I think that
if this fight ends in devastating
fashion like kale collards kale and
Floyd I think there's no way Floyd stop
but you wouldn't make a bet on that I
did I did make a bet on that that he
would ko Floyd yeah but you've made
multiple bet I'm a bum you're covering
you're covering your base yeah so you're
gonna win money and then lose it well
you're going to one boy I'll win more
than I'll lose for sure so your bets are
what my money bet the money bets on I
said the questionable sexual bets that
you made meaning the money bets or what
the for round of the winner run one more
more round which I would love to take a
nap 26 one odds of that's that's that's
good [ __ ] bet that was you guys have
in on what you make may I guess does and
then the other one is if that kind of
get a wins via KO detail that's not
happening if I get if there's ko TKO it
comes from Conor we we all know that
Floyd Mayweather is not a knockout
puncher he hasn't been a knockout
puncher for years whatever that's never
been his team Conor McGregor
you guys are acting like he's Foreman
Tyson or one of
big like knockout punches with knockout
power like he's been knocking out people
for years he didn't knock out is he he's
on out dollars for sure knock out a
little guy that he can't even get on
rides a great adventure or Chad Mendes
know who was the guy that Aldo Aldo the
guy he's not on get up darts in 13
seconds yeah but he was the greatest 145
or of all time but he's a guy like when
you take him to like Disneyland he's not
tall enough to get on the rides right
the little guy L don't could be tough
he's not that small amazing a Chapman
but he ran into the punch well however
you want to talk to Mike I have to avoid
me where the Floyd member is not running
into a punch
yeah but he's knocked out like Eddie
Alvarez who's out losing you former
world champion after kicking him
punching him I can filled starch them
spoke but was it just like I like a
boxing like there was no kicking there's
no no but I'll die right up being kicked
in the legs no ok so sorts a different
thing knocked out or knocked at us like
Italy not at all but enemy I'm knockout
artist there's so many different you
know there's so much better than there's
so many different variable you mean you
are fighting there's like there's no
bogeys get yes right a vicious me
punching you in the face yeah yeah like
I was like pulled out thing yeah but if
I say you know I could kick you then
you're worried about the kick boom yeah
but you're worried about that
yeah the don't grab me like that don't
tell me like what's the thing is is if
is if Connor lands that big left hand so
let's just say that this is how I know
you must be flappy yes let's say the
feel goodness he goes knock on our lands
a big left hand knows what's right well
I wonder why on your paperwork I ever we
got a [ __ ] run your files
hey here's the thing if Floyd lands a
clean right hand straight Frank straight
right and you know he did good with the
drill right you and if Connor lands are
flush left you mean at the same time
same time there's only one of them that
will get knocked out because one of them
has knocked out power and it's not Floyd
Mayweather in this fight there's one
only one of them has finishing
capabilities and it's not Floyd I I
don't know I don't see how you can base
that on anything I don't see how you
could base Conor McGregor's
knockout power as a boxer based on
anything because all his MMA fights it's
never been just even when he's knocking
people out his lock outs are by his left
hand but I'm saying there's
other things happening yeah but how did
I want I'm from the hand the AL battle
was a definite exception the guy right
that was a weird fight that was a joke a
joke the best 145 of all time he ran
into the punch got knocked out one day
when he landed a punch though Aldo yeah
he land a left hook they both lay in the
same time I'm not gonna sit here and try
to argue because I know you know so much
more than me but no I get what you're
saying but I see I don't see from you
now here happens we don't know what he
has it's a huge x-factor but the thing
with with them and me when people go off
he just wants to rounds he wins the
fight I disagree I'm saying that this
fight isn't as big as a spectacle or
circus if it makes it out to be
you're gonna get a legit 5 grams I agree
and I don't think that there's any
physical duress although it's boxing I
mean I you know it's part I just don't
think there's any physical duress that
Mayweather will put him we'll put
McGregor under that he will make it so
he can't finish the fight so even if me
we're the ones I don't think he's gonna
I don't think he's going to knock him
out and I just think the dress that
McGregor is used to taking with the Diaz
fight yeah you know like I don't think
like that's going to happen in this
fight but it but this theoretical thing
of well what if they thought a Natalie
is about student that's not that's too
hard for militant isn't it Dante what's
Winston yeah I really freaked Chris
right now do it's my friend what's Chris
do you just remember he's a person he's
a person who hit me - MMA
shut up years ago snow hey Chris don't
text Rappaport with that stupid say - hi
Chris you cut that [ __ ] out do not
text wrap that bulls you're not fighting
in a back alley doesn't matter they're
not fighting at 3:30 after school
doesn't matter
don't you all know that it's yes is that
the dumbest conversation open it's so
slow over time to my man Chris Chris
stop [ __ ] texting me with that [ __ ]
Chris stop stop it now right it's coming
from big brown right now I have to blow
you up on a [ __ ] nationally televised
address we had to do this he said well
if T doesn't matter what are you [ __ ]
call a manageable and break up the fight
between Connor and Sidda now I might as
well be in a fool shut your mouth Chris
um chief any sad that's my he's my guy
who turned me on to
turn me on to our and I'm a a long time
ago when I was just like I like it man
yeah I like it
you've been talking all that [ __ ] I all
look your professional [ __ ] tiger I get
all over on everywhere I go bar stool
yeah oh you know rattler yeah that aizen
yes I love how great is really good he's
my favorite yeah and he's like he's
smart he's a straight guy he knows his
[ __ ] and he's got a good sense of humor
I told rich he came in the back as uh so
he's on my floor as I'm out clothing and
all that stuff you were talking about
clothing clothing with him because I
came in with this dope jacket a good
jacket on you don't know clothes and sit
to stand out anyways we wearing those
[ __ ] shoes not the state with us
these are special cases these were for
Julio Chavez anyways so he goes once you
put some Spurs on him and ride the [ __ ]
out of here on your horse dude if you
don't know fast if you can't get in the
game bro you like talented guy you like
talents on we all don't hear me don't
compare me to Kalin I really [ __ ]
well why is he saw the beard yeah and he
dies it guy so he goes is there anything
we need to stay away from I said I told
us as long as you don't call this fight
a circus or an act I'm good yo okay no
problem then we're on there that's how
big three got brought up till he goes oh
there's a circus summit whoa no circus
would be Michael Phelps versus that
great white that's some [ __ ] right
circus would be rapport pitching three
on three is a real sport
that's a circuit you know three on three
years of reals and down a real life
that's a pick-up day now let me tell you
something bro let me slimming all that
you only give me four let me tell you
some Brandon first of all I know the
saying that the media hype you were
right there let me go back to the circus
big three is real the competition is
Brendan you haven't watched it
respectively say you haven't given you
the watch you know having you as fish
okay I'm Tom don't you take when you
Tommy let's take a four point shot I'm
out let's go let's let's ride dragons
I'm out for a guaranteed I mark this
down in history put this in the
Smithsonian before we die so it'd be in
the next 50 years probably short of that
but we have 4.4 shot in the NBA I
guaran-fucking-tee you I get you well
let's make a bet right now what you want
to take odds you want to go well this
it's the one round I do you want to yeah
we're
I'll bet you $100,000 that there's a
four-point shot within two years you're
going to be rich
within before we die there will be a 4.5
an be Heil $200,000 yes wait but I'm
gonna know Li I'm gonna be on my
deathbed guys don't rap hills behind
glad no you know I'm going to be like
jealous ship it over I won laid man I'm
old age onto harassing including sexual
assaults on a nurse dude why would them
day to a four point shot what's wrong
with the game now because the
three-point shot like these guys are all
so far behind the three-point line now
they're so good and Steph Curry like
he's shooting not good so the four point
shot in the in the big three
first of all it gives another end of
excitement and in the NBA to have a
three-point shot but the guys are so far
behind the three-point arc now that
they're going to I guarantee they're
going to add it again but it again
already needs more defense like just too
much all psyche I agree it's out its out
of hell there is is off I totally agree
and it's it's you know it's just
shooting and dribbling exhibitions and I
think you needed to Det
but now you have to like have a happy
myth like I like a happy medium I think
it's too much you know as much as I
loved Kyrie Irving I love them I love
them but it's like if it takes why does
it take it and I love Kyrie six moves
that book just go by an old man got a
one move and go like anybody in the
Jordan NBA level like a few six moves at
the level of balinese you're gonna
[ __ ] get by it's a book just yeah
Isiah Thomas not the Isiah Tyler is now
Detroit Pistons anytime it says boom
boom
Don that's it yeah so you can log on
this big three love it love it
what's your involvement besides being a
reporter I love that
I'm Nicole they're calling me Tommy the
Howard Cosell the big smile humbly out
tears you I'll tear you that's what
they're calling you ever date a lot of
people refer to me like they'll be like
oh there's Michael Rapaport the Howard
Cosell of the big three
chin when we were downstairs and you
picked me up wasn't that guy just saying
oh the house hotels a big foodies like
there's the Howard Cosell typically
sometimes they don't even know my name
they'll be like oh [ __ ] there's the
Howard Cosell the big three I'm still
just telling but I love it I just needed
such a [ __ ] fan and
Baskerville love it you love and I will
bust your ass 101 but you know you're
not Bieber I will [ __ ] you up
listen I don't think about looking down
a bride goes under your house so no one
has to see her and it will bring change
we're going to film it
bring [ __ ] chin we'll bring all the
kids while I'm telling you a [ __ ]
solid here no I'm trying to do a real
solid you like Conor McGregor tried to
do Paulie that [ __ ] dirtbag I'm gonna
do him like you did my man Paul have you
like all your heroes all your years of
fighting all your years of training we
talk about practice has anyone ever
released chopped up edited sparring
footage ever this wide that's why you
can't say it's not a circus kind of
regretting oh that was I know I had Paul
II pushed it a little bit but the master
you probably ate for 12 rounds and pull
it in [ __ ] smack him around for 12
rep Ollie Malignaggi didn't punch Conor
McGregor in the face a bunch of times
want they release that or release the
whole 12 rounds that footage was cool he
hit him you mean to tell me out of all
the foot if you just have that those 250
meters echeveria from two different
angle I hear you but ting to his release
and who's controlling this so I'm never
with you Dana Dane is my man I [ __ ] with
you he shook the rebel ticket
but it's like you and where's the
where's your sparring footage from all
years your training that is some
[ __ ] Longway actors which are more
practical my practice which almost a kit
of water I'd like to do some undertaking
a virgin all right I talked to Polly
yesterday and I was like to end it Silas
I'm writing a line here cuz I'll see I'm
team Conor I know it happened with Polly
the thing with Polly and I think he just
hurt because part that he's in going
there's gonna be all good like yeah I'm
not going with you he goes I past all
that [ __ ] but I'm coming here to help
you so it should be all good
Connors going nominate I thought [ __ ]
I'm literally bringing you here I'm not
learning shivering I'm here to [ __ ] you
up so they both had two different
agendas did one of them while they get
paid to do it
Polly [ __ ] was supposed to get paid but
Polly left early so well I'm sure he
knows you fight him for real well that's
the thing that sounds like Polly wants
to fight so if kana has good show nyan
Floyd he might want to get Floyd you're
crazy
he ain't having a good showing against
and if he beats if he somehow so now my
awesome out rap what the [ __ ] are you
gonna do [ __ ] my [ __ ] head what am I
gonna say you know like I listen what
are you going to what's a good showing
to you though you're out let's say let
us say you're an average living in right
gonna happen what to get your let me say
they go 12 rounds and it's like a split
decision and it would forget the biggest
judges cuz you know who [ __ ] knows with
that how that's gonna work they can't
count them yeah the rock scene you know
if you wanna go you know everyone's
going we know what a good showing is it
wouldn't not so good sure that's all
take on Irwin's uh five out on the
judges car yeah that's why it's [ __ ]
up because like my friend Chris who is
like the judge because I'm like this is
boxing in a crazy match oh I definitely
think that [ __ ] she took I say why
don't you [ __ ] call me that's a good
bet I don't know you're a hater so I
didn't you know I kind of kept it to
myself but but you know I'll know if
it's a good showing in my heart
forget the judge I wanna be able to tell
right of course of course like you know
but we all look like Madonna we thought
Maidana had a good showing a physical
showing that was a good showing and they
want to rewatch that first fight you
were like he hit him once the rest of it
was against the world's Floyd was under
any duress he was you know he was
mauling him but then the second fight it
was like True Blood but let it was a
good show which Allah so let's say will
not be a good showing if he did what
Maidana did alright I expect more out of
Conor to be honest let's say let's say
if Connor kissed Floyd wobbles them the
third round it's like oh [ __ ] knees
close finish them and then Floyd goes on
to win and by a decision that would be a
good show if he just hits him with one
shot like he's laying my god but he
hasn't like out on his feet and then say
by the Bell and then Boyd comes back in
a fight I don't think it's gonna happen
to be tough to do see all these little
[ __ ] guys that he fights in MMA
they're standing still no one's moving
around no one shoulder rolling like
shoulder rolling what is a shoulder roll
table side don't know it better than me
I know I think he's gonna have some
trouble with shoulder rolling why
because a Conor [ __ ] McGregor the
nine boxers going to do it forty nine
other people haven't even thirty nine
traditional boxes what are you just go
back to Paulie
let's go back
okay good luncheon where's the [ __ ]
water yeah and then one warning
he needs more of her guys a year needs
funny I agree [ __ ] you I'll be brain
goes shows up to an all-star game you
don't have a [ __ ] Indian we do what
we [ __ ] we got rid of our interns yet
to move on so we're waiting for another
one usually they give us water coffee so
chin has played double duty man [ __ ]
chin goddammit you give me one to cheer
maybe get him to just me one yeah free
cold case out know him that one run
[ __ ] [ __ ] I rap sorry brother they
seem too big three here but with Paul
you think it was dirty huh well I think
Polly's feelings are hurt his feelings
should be hurt this is a two-time
champion it's disrespectful it's not
professional and I code a little bit I
agree with exactly it's [ __ ] Geico
and it's it's it's you know it's like I
come in there to spar what's all my
practice my coming though spot and help
you I just think I think that I think
the communication was in on because
Paulie when you talk to Paulie sounds
like man this was going to happen to
come in yeah we had been sparring spar
and then we'd be all good in Connors
like nah bringing her to [ __ ] you up man
that's why you're here
I'll pay you to fly you and all that I'm
little just trying to [ __ ] you up so I
think both feelings were hurt you know
but also colored it released that Dana
did it's a one in the same Brendan not
really though Brendan why you say why
the [ __ ] was wild [ __ ] was Dana there
well then one in this day has a UFC
facility he's using Dana's gym it's one
want to get his own gym since he's so
[ __ ] rich because my gosh is that one
yeah but I'm saying come on don't try to
like O'Connor Lisa footage I mean Dana
released the footage there was a
nondisclosure I'm sure except for Dana
White and then and it wasn't just Dana's
footage because there was two or three
different angles using those two clips
well not always sad probably does
there's a button to the forty toes were
there Dana's there's all these cameras
it's whack man here's once you released
the 12 ramp released a 12 round you mean
to tell me he didn't get he didn't
[ __ ] smack him around and 12 [ __ ]
around he just beat him up and Paulie
Malignaggi just got beat up for 12 rub
no I don't think Holly's out there
no we didn't I don't think so I know we
didn't I don't think that happened it's
[ __ ] I'm supposed to but it's gonna
be fun are you going to fight I'm
working it
oh you're gonna be ringside I'm working
the fight that's gonna be [ __ ] if I
leave mom working for Showtime Monday
through Saturday of that week that week
we're doing pre shows post-fight shows
all these shows out there the big three
finals one o'clock that day if you're
not work and you come out of the big
three that'd be fun the day of the fight
at one it might be tough for you I'd be
cool to come though it'd be cool we come
in and because you know you guys had to
get the [ __ ] up arena though right you
know they look at me you know you have
to leave right you know that it wasn't
for free I know but I love he was like
hey man we're not and you don't biggest
fight of all time and now a three three
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out a guy just to get the
[ __ ] out mill price so decide milk yeah
what's the same thing who's laying that
day what do you mean like who's playing
on that Saturday what are the finals so
who's in it we don't know that the the
playoffs are coming up in the next two
were like the biggest names who could
make it a I his team might be in there
I'm Gary Payton team on 12 a Larry no
you're not playing is coaching all these
their coaches um probably Kenny Martin
team Rick Mahorn is his coach Rick
Mahorn old school man yeah um and I
guarantee this as you do this will get
up they pay me [ __ ] you pain I know but
yeah of course no problem pay me I mean
ice cube [ __ ] you pay me yeah ice cube
[ __ ] you pay me leave it out for you I
don't do any event on the day so it's a
win-win because you paid me and
everything up but doesn't hurt your
attendance and I wanna come in Vegas on
that weekend at one o'clock the [ __ ]
moon at six nights gonna be a lunatic
the gaming house the tenants been
Loveline great that is it good it looks
packed I told you guys paper in the room
or said people at your noggins mother
fear they're [ __ ] in there man
Brooklyn was sold out a few places like
they sold-out Barclays yesterday it
Staples was dope I mean it's going it's
coming back next year next year's gonna
have more players like the margin
between retired players at 40 and
retired players at 34
Kobe my play damn son Kevin Garnett
Ray Allen so it'll be like one one year
out of the league as opposed to five
years out of eight
and keep going sure how much how much
these guys get paid dad is it good money
they're making money but they're not
making sure students to do it they're
doing it dudes are making money though
like they're making money in there's
prize money
but they just like the competition the
thing that I was most impressed with and
I think that people when they watch the
games is this ain't no disrespect to the
hall Globetrotters no disrespect to
charity games these [ __ ] are
playing they're playing and they're
playing hard and they love it you know
what the one thing that Bond's me about
it's humble that you know the four
seconds that you've watched well yeah
well I don't need to you know why
because the names of the teams drive me
nuts
what are they like the Brooklyn front
you know bulldozers no it's like that
the LA slap takes like it's nothing real
like why not make it more professional
because you guys actually playing then
you have like the but like urology is a
team tri-state as a team Three's Company
three something okay three-headed
monster the three has big three what's
the new monsters movie no but the other
one it's a cartoon ball hogs the ball
hog okay trilogy so somebody names are a
little fun but listen you watch the
games if you're available
courtside I love to come the 26 you come
there when there's no cameras we'll see
what you could do something all right
we'll play a little one-on-one 211 a bus
trash maybe I could give you a low so
when you're doing the broadcast you got
a little right here just to keep you on
it who's the last person who played
one-on-one [ __ ] it's been a minute I
don't want to want the last one I want
to be toss on plate I played 21 with
Vinny Testaverde Vinny Testaverde with
Tim Tebow and his brother and Vinny
Testaverde [ __ ] me
Kenny play ball almost dude could do
more penny horns I'm he dunked on me but
it disabled his Heisman Trophy nuts in
my face oldest [ __ ] Vinny Testaverde
some rich as [ __ ] he don't throw he was
like 50 Outback steak houses he dunked
on me straighter how big is he six six
one-handed dunk one hand down the lane
pinky ball play it has good defense
I bet is really good they could all do
multi [ __ ] Vinny Testaverde another uni
given Vinny touch three not three on
three he could bar and who
saying that beautiful jheri-curl tan
skin dumped on me with his Heisman and
skin jheri curl in his [ __ ] just
killing the game to kill him the game
maybe go to his house and watch all
these highlights tapes of him and his
Baltimore Ravens I get through that [ __ ]
actor like us all into it yeah he was
rough in the NFL he had a good run all
how did he [ __ ] Vinny Testaverde he's
rich now you can't have everything out
high outro fee is fifty Outbacks
that's alright following [ __ ] my mommy
he was just a bunch of Browns up what
about your uh your boy t-ball what are
you games like come on doing well he
call it to the major about circus is he
major longbow caliber bro do you keep up
with him do you pray with them do you
guys pray to God I got to learn someone
but do you like curse around them oh
yeah he knows me for me I mean he
listened he was with me you know he
searched before I see it with me know he
knows exactly know what to do he knows
do him know he listen you talking about
a guy people can hate on mall they want
but I don't [ __ ] hate on he's doing
well man I know yeah in the face with a
baseball two days together
yeah alright yeah it's cool so the other
bad one I make this better I want to
make with you you could tell me what you
want I'm not doing this if coulda
shoulda woulda
my bet is this I live in a big [ __ ]
house it's big yeah your middle mouse
big I gotta say it's not smaller yeah
hey I want you in my house clean the
whole [ __ ] thing huh and I'm not
talking about and I'm not talking about
like why padam Tomo I want that
[ __ ] like a clean sir and I
can't hire so I got [ __ ] I hire
someone to do it no mother you can hire
someone no [ __ ] no man I got big ass
glass windows I want them both [ __ ] I
don't want off my dog wait what's the
bet though for I got Floyd winning the
fight bro
that's a terrible odds I need Vegas odds
then even your whole [ __ ] [ __ ] clean
a lot of the house windows everything
garage and my [ __ ] car and when you
clean my garage Oh bro when you clean
the car is it the car's not that big but
if I get to the car to the blotter yes a
lot of detail by the time you get to my
car you're going to be so worn out I'll
clean you're going to be exhausted okay
I want the other modal on - no I got
fake grass laughing - but but but but I
want the pool the pulse
you know swept yeah oh I want the house
cleaned and I want our detail 50 G's or
so this is one example
[ __ ] that big brown mr. dick pic better
you're gonna clean my [ __ ] house and
now what do you want me to do well this
isn't a fair bet you the are paint brown
the dot u k-- the odds
[ __ ] this week I mean you're the answer
and coulda shoulda what's not even a man
she's just a big outs of big [ __ ] I
want you in that I'm not doing anything
you're just starting those kids I like
if I'm gonna do worse I can't have
damaged our work just me videotaping
just me videos it and it's just you and
you bring your own [ __ ] cleaning so I
can either use them role you bring up
I'm up I don't bring your book a
Dustbuster
I want your sprays and my counters
marble so don't you can't use the same
spray use on a window oh my god gear to
make this exam is for Mme Conor McGregor
come on that's your guy if he does it he
might not come out well you could tell
me what you want I was just gonna say
like a real nice dinner life's fine I'm
talkin expensive whatever you want any
place you want la you could starve
yourself for a week that's the bet you
come clean this [ __ ] outfit feel I'm
sorry I get to videotape alright
father I have to where I'm at clothes
[ __ ] you have to wear a clothes
you want to be new don't you know you
want to do dicta I'm not doing it no
[ __ ] other I don't know if you're in
some weird fantasy like solar and clean
and me me you and you're me I made out
septum
I don't know maybe in some weird [ __ ]
now I can I don't like a Christian not
do any may print on the front I have an
air cannon but now now having any kind
of party like I see what the hell I
don't want that I would be more mr.
kalin bet you know I don't know man but
who is this guy you made a dick pic that
way I was just doing some press to New
York and he kept talking show it dude
I'm so confident I'll tell you what if
he doesn't win a round tomorrow I'll
send you dick pic it's an IRA melee I
would offer that up cuz uh why is it
something that would be in sort of your
things about like you know what I need
eight deals clean my [ __ ] house shine
my [ __ ] car that kind of thing you're
like I'll send you a dick pic what makes
you think
I want hey well hey they did he went
really around the aw man it's a bad bet
so the Betty all mad with money because
I tell you know you look down on luck I
don't you know [ __ ] you know I'll bet
your Rolex cuz then he's doing it you
know no let's do some me and get do for
free that all [ __ ] obstacle my
house cleaning so if you win you get a
dick pic of him and you're happy if I'm
not here sir put your hands put on
social media his dick pic yeah and
you're in it and you're you're like
that's cool well I had nothing else like
that's that's good thing walnuts again
you get the first copy if that's gonna
be bad for him
kids these days man that's what he
wanted I use you said how about a dick
pic I I'm so confident I'm not gonna
lose the bet I would never wanna blast
this dick I got Mayweather why draymond
green I don't want that yeah - Tom who -
Tom that eggplant but it was he had a
two-tone dick yeah he did is like a
weird lollipop yeah he looked fishy how
would you do that and if you didn't hate
you though huh he didn't mean to take
you know hard it is to take a dick pic
no he's saying he didn't mean to upload
it to where he uploaded so you just want
to take it for himself
notice you meant to send to his girl a
Senate like on snapchat Lee but he
actually exited Eliza
your girl doesn't want your dick pic
nobody nobody's girl why if you already
seen the loaf you don't want to dick pic
with this the thing good girls are
savages these days man some want it
listen you've been out of the game a
little long so some requests it but if
you if you're already with the girl and
you've already you've already had she's
all session either that's what I'm
saying he's saying his girl like why
would you say and if you need like well
the girl he's dating the thing is like
it's not like an outrageous dick to
blast nominee and I'm saying like that's
why I kind of believe him I felt bad for
him a little bit
listen I [ __ ] with dream on I that was
him he was on a lot he was on a high
they won the championship you know you
see him your boy Connor roasted him so
bad
did you see him he came out in that
Jersey he knows do we go wheel [ __ ]
with you we [ __ ] before him time went
who the [ __ ] is this guy look at the
Jersey a [ __ ] 1.4 come any sandy I
don't bounce basketball eyes down I
bounce heads 1.4 Canada that was good
he's a good [ __ ] talker right now he's
agustín's overhead but best you've ever
had and good for a white guy but if a
black guy did the same [ __ ] when black
athletes behave the same way a lot of
times they could call them noxious they
get called thugs they get called these
other things but with Conor McGregor who
stole this whole style from Mayweather
restos whole style from Ali who stole
herself from gorgeous work with me
whether it's cute it's more it's more
it's more appetizing you think guys I
think what about the race law / uh the
reason gets a pass on the racist stuff
is because he's from Ireland like saying
boy and monkey and I was there and
trusted I'm with you rap like I don't
play that [ __ ] at all
Brendan is from Ireland where's that
[ __ ] like a Saturn you don't know
that you shouldn't call black people boy
that that's inappropriate what [ __ ]
world it he's from Ireland he's not from
[ __ ] Pluto nah hey I get it but I
waited called a monkey's and [ __ ] no no
he said that kids closed up the day I
dance like a monkey dance monkey dance
so wait so you're just because you're
from Ireland that's an excuse to say
that crappy excuse I'm saying it I give
him a little more slack there and then
we're not accessible anywhere you know I
to be honest I didn't know ty got to
college I had this badass Lawrence
Vickers our team captain I said
something where I was like uh don't be
quit playing boy like joking around cuz
I heard in a song I was he's from the
fifth Ward in Houston when I said boy I
mean I learned real quick he didn't like
oh my god yeah but with Connor I get it
but see what I know they still gonna
clock into with the [ __ ] talking to like
LaHood so who's the best [ __ ] talker in
basketball recruit no one really has
that personality no it's good but I'm
just saying all this like who dude that
that's my problem with these mainstream
sports like in NFL NBA MLB
you to a post-fight Shantz they were
good I'm just lucky to get by all of
them everyone they're giving us [ __ ]
answers he's was fighting diet that do
not I don't like I grab out that I agree
I would love that the page of Scotland
Tom Brady like how's the game you can go
I'm gonna [ __ ] all over them they can't
hold me I want that real I agree and and
and and in this day and age like when
you talk [ __ ] or if you show emotion you
like
they mad shame you yeah and it all
happened when Tom Brady remember when
Tom Brady lost to the Seattle Seahawks
Richard Sherman you mad bro yeah man go
instead of going damn [ __ ] man [ __ ]
you didn't saving Richard Sherman
publicly Matt shamed Tom Brady hashtag
mail you mad bro enough it became a
Twitter handle I found were temporary
out of it
yeah I'm [ __ ] it you shouldn't be you
shouldn't be ashamed to show your anger
I don't get it you just [ __ ] kicked
man I'm [ __ ] man no I don't get why
I'm professional sports capala James I
know the the defense really came out
strong tonight uh
I'm fine doctor [ __ ] it's that's the
thing [ __ ] out man I agree they're
[ __ ] up I agree if you insult the
referees you get fined if you insult the
officiating you get fined if you insult
the other two I get it because of the
financial implication of it but I think
there should again you should spread it
out like like I should be like breathing
have you heard about with Bryce Harper
him he's like baseball's [ __ ] boring
and they don't let's talk about anything
we have to act like he's like that's why
the ratings are down did they find him
I'm sure that he's one of the few guys
who has a personality and what are you
like 300 million dollars so what $25,000
finds like ah like a pack of gum but
with these with these mainstream sports
everyone's so scared to show personnel I
agree it's not good then what did you
take on the John Jones Cormier uh like I
mean he won that fight good did he look
do you hear they won the Soyuz on Good
Morning America with Michael Strahan
which is hilarious to say but uh so John
was on good more America they go what's
next he is you know Rogers is not going
to be able to fight til next year I'd
like that fight like that's the fight he
wants fight Brock and he is they want me
if I'm a square garden but they stacked
me 10% of segments were gardens so that
ain't happen because the fight at masks
we're going to get taxing even more
fight Brock no to fight anyone but the
cuz mask reruns in November they go
could you fight Gustav in November he
goes I won't do that mask regarding to
that they attacked me two months I don't
see anything wrong with that now so
you'll see could we could pay him more
so they can make the fight hat how much
money does John Jones make a fight
guesstimate like our MMA fighters making
money the top top top who's that shut
who Conor
how much did he make verse
Nate took deferred sacrifice right soon
I think more than a million dollars
machen I don't know at least that was
his pay
probably more like 7 million that's a
[ __ ] joke that's a [ __ ] giant how
much did Nate make by 2 million that's a
[ __ ] joke but your timeout outliers
usually no one gets even close to that
you know I made maybe John made a
million why see what we got the guys by
the balls oh wait wait wait wait where
there's no Union there's no there's no
fighter so how much you think John made
against DC well he was coming back and
he come back so they done report said
five hundred thousand if I gamma
disclose bonus maybe a mil I don't know
if he has paper you percentages and
who's making all the money do you see
that is [ __ ] up that is [ __ ] up that
John Jones
these guys are out there putting their
life on the [ __ ] line or health and
you know it's like we talked about
football CT boxing you know the
long-term effects of MMA you could say
what you want we don't know what they
are you don't know like we didn't know
what dick buck gets it all the guys in
the NFL like while it was happening and
now you see the ramifications
we don't know what Chuck Liddell is
going to be like a 20s and this is no
disrespect against any of them know you
bit again to your point if you talked a
few those older guys MMA guys trouble
already you can see signs already and
and you know the thing about the Cormier
fight and always disgust you system out
and even on Joe Rogan said some about it
by the way Joe Rogan can I get on his
[ __ ] podcast you can you given up I'm
going on the show this week you want me
to maybe say so no I mean I think that
that's like that's like [ __ ]
pay-per-view [ __ ] like everybody's been
on Joe Rogan Joe what the [ __ ] man I've
been [ __ ] you since Fear Factor I'm
not doing we nearly three and a half
hours [ __ ] I'm an hour get the [ __ ] out
he only does three hours listen I'll do
an hour take a nap for half hour wake up
and I'm not doing any [ __ ] but you
can't hang oh I gotta have enough to
talk about and I like to talk but three
[ __ ] hours of this [ __ ] oh don't
worry it'll go by fast such a guy like
Joe but yet he's but he's not into
basketball and we talk MMA could choose
some [ __ ]
conspiracy theory I lack [ __ ] I
could talk to him about my resentment
over calling Ronda Rousey the craziest
of all time we take that back
does he oh yeah publicly no yeah I'm
sure yeah yeah I think everyone fell
into that kind of great white hope yep
when we weren't in real quick other than
the great white and hopeful career of
Ronda Rousey I mean listen man anyone
who hangs around the game long enough
like it ends in a sad sad sad story like
you know my boy Rashad Evans just fought
a few weekends ago and I'm watching and
I met her just watching her shot after
he won the belt off Chuck Liddell and
I'm watching them I'm psychic oh my god
he's on the undercard on this Mexico
card fighting a no-name er he lost it's
like this is how everyone's movie ends
man that's [ __ ] you God none of these
guys are making money
no not lifelong money no when you're
done you're done you're done done
there's that there's nothing that is
[ __ ] up you know and the UFC should
compassionately and and the fighters
should should should learn from boxing
and all the mistakes at boxing me and
all the exploitation that boxing content
boxing is still [ __ ] Floyd Mayweather
talk about an outlier
De La Hoya and these guys are just
catching on yes you know it's like the
majority these guys was with MMA though
and listen I've had discussions with
them in a union the athletes association
fighters whatever and they all come to
me and I tell them man the fighters have
to want to change it can't be these
lawyers or you can see money here all
the fighters have to get together like
we're not fighting unless something gets
done that's never gonna happen when
you're young and hungry you're thinking
about fighting well you taught you
listen to fires go now I'm not worried
about that stuff own we're about fine I
get that now because you're 19 you
[ __ ] 20 in your ear you you want to
get you know it's like all you have that
lies like John Jones Conor Brock Ronda
although all these crazy making money
who could make the change but they're
like we're getting paid what he wants to
do that's [ __ ] up so so who's with
this month I used to have like I said
come on gain and help them out it's not
Dana's problem found a business if I'm
Apple and I can hire people to make
phones for three cents an hour and
they're not going to say anything about
it I'm gonna keep doing it because I'm a
businessman it's up to those workers
right
we're not doing this [ __ ] so with the
fighters like it's up to you guys
I can talk to uh moon in the face how
unfair it is but you guys aren't getting
together so I'm out man I agree you
don't want it I'm out
so how much do you think I know I know
these are like I'm like throwing like
fortune-teller how much do you think
Rhonda made in her career just from
fighting just from just from in the ring
combat ten million dollars yeah maybe
that is [ __ ] up that is [ __ ]
stutters more you tell me John Jones
made a million dollars off that fight or
Conor McGregor made two million dollars
to fight [ __ ] Diaz and this bloodbath
of five rounds and that's rough two
million dollars no wonder he's gonna do
whatever you can to fight Floyd
Mayweather and pie fight Paulie metics
what we gonna fight Paulie I wouldn't
you Paul he's retired
Paulie wants that fight if a thing about
it because because so the UFC is taking
a big cut of this so let's say Kane
Connor has McGregor promotions right so
let's say this let's say Conor McGregor
and let's say in this weird fight world
he has a good showing in Floyd
Mayweather people like damn imma [ __ ]
actually box he rocked Floyd still lost
though and then there's actually bad
blood between him and Paulie in Connors
man I just dude put my own promotion
fight Paulie make forty thirty forty
million or I think with UFC fight Nate
Diaz give him a huge chunk maybe make 10
mil or they gonna give me some killer
and Tony person could be [ __ ] you lemma
fight Paulie so so what do they sign
lifelong contracts to do you have seen
like when does it end it's usually a
depends the usually made to do four to
six ideals so one is one of these guys
going to go [ __ ] it I'm Conor McGregor
let's let's say let's say whatever
happens with the Floyd fight let's say a
year two years his contract runs out
let's just philosophically says he's
gonna say [ __ ] this yeah
you want to fight let's fight we keep
the money yeah exactly
he cut there's been only one guy to
really do that to me Connor Connor could
go you know what let's do Paulie do it
in Dublin that huge arena 80 or I would
Rob back that 80,000 people quality
let's do it we'll share the gate I would
respect that I'll dope with that thing I
would respect that and then you have the
alley at two now with boxing which is
the I mean if you look up the ollie act
I don't [ __ ] it up but bring it up
chin but with ollie act and with the
the it helps the boxes out so much more
and that's what the fighters are trying
to get but again the fighters they don't
fight for it right now I can't read that
[ __ ] you can read that [ __ ] yeah I can
but it's so it's basically um scroll up
for me jinsoyun stars o Muhammad Ali
boxing Reform Act commonly referred to
as ollie act is a federal wall that was
introduced in 1999 so not that long ago
enacted Congress protect the rights and
welfare of safety act by expanding upon
legislators bla exploitation conflict of
interest so you can't have this the
promoter and the fighter you know I'm
saying so Dana's the promoter the owner
and manages the fighters how much money
Dana Dana might have well when they
still do UFC made 400 million that's
right they sold eight but Dana still you
know minority owner still the president
that doesn't act in response to
widespread abuse of boxers by means of
exploitation rigged rankings and brick
Matthew read good so you can't have you
can't have you know the UFC making the
rankings making the fight decide where
you're gonna fight who you gonna fight
then get a portion of the gate just
signing your contract so you need a
third party right
I agree Val yeah that's what I agree
Leah I agree yeah so we taught her he
could do that he should do that I think
he didn't do something like that
I don't unless for years to get a
percentage of the company which we'd
never find out too later down the road I
think him some huge gate otherwise why
are you gonna fight him you see isn't
the fight that everybody wants to see in
the UFC he beat Nate Nate beat him at 70
both were great yep
why isn't that happening because because
because he can make a hundred million
dollars fighting Floyd man okay but but
after that cuz he's gonna make ten
million fighting him when he could fight
Paulie for 60 million would you would
you say that fights never gonna happen
I think it's gonna happen but the UFC is
gonna have to bend the rules I could
never had to before in terms of giving
them money and Connor's finally has all
the chips in this corner cuz this what's
happening right now
Connor is dangling the carrot in front
of the UFC say scone no no let me do
this wilco promote this let me get this
money I'll get a
you guys get 44 million let me just do
this I'll come to your fight then he's
gonna do it have a good show night [ __ ]
you pay me where's my money you can't
make the fight without me
and what about Nate you know Nate Nate
you know Nate's a guy he wants to fight
too
and Nate's going to get paid off that
fight too but again he can't he's not
got the demands college to have he's
still going to get paid his regular
salary that's [ __ ] ridiculous why is
that I found all the [ __ ] Nate Diaz why
is that something that like the UFC
wants to do he's Amish gold but this is
and here's the counter-argument to that
well why that's like cool here's the
counter-argument no rap if you're a
owner of a business and you can that's
your copy of a contract or your
employees going bro I'm worse worth more
than this pay me a million so the 500
grand ago but it says your salads timer
again you're like my god here's a mil
right I don't know what it's a scary
situation his Nate been on this show
no what so what does Nate Diaz up to I
[ __ ] with Nate Diaz so I [ __ ] with the
[ __ ] Diaz brother
yeah most people do they you know
they've been he's been offered fight so
I think he's just waiting for the Stano
fight and then Nick got suspended
because you sada if you have to tell me
we're about to be still an active
fighter and he just was like [ __ ] I
don't smoke weed right
yeah it's regal an MMA inkay and you're
seeing outside it's not your right
like if you're in camp like getting
ready for a fight you can't smoke
outside the Kami smoke all the weed you
want they don't test you they test you
but you're not going to get flagged for
recreational drugs well yeah that was
Nate I think he's literally just waiting
for that trilogy fight he's hoping that
happens here but the thing with Nate
lemons have them happen what do we do
so what would be another he turned down
Tony Ferguson you know some other fights
what's the next big fight like exciting
fight UFC fight that's going to happen
not a potential John Jones versed at
fight that's gonna be a joke Jones gonna
kick his ass Western quick yeah which
would be awesome
I would it be all that that why don't I
ride a why would a guy that was
convicted of steroids and and don't you
want to see that no you don't see that I
don't want to I mean I want is a sheik
is a criteria the Bronx was not scary
dude in that cage he's scary and any so
much you know physically bigger like I
want to see the bully get beat up how
about that against a guy who you know
who has all the skills to do it and
what's next for Cormier
I thought he retired he came out on MMA
hour saying you know not only get a my
gonna fight again but I'm gonna fight
John Jones again eventually I think that
I I don't see what's left for him to do
but listen I love D seeds and if it's in
this heart keep doing it I don't get why
he's doing it did it offend you those
extra punches he took where he was
clearly knocked out yeah I pissed me off
why does that happen and would that ref
Big John he's the very best we have he's
the best way I [ __ ] a Big John - he goes
in that back to a fight you got to make
sure you know like I don't want stop it
early if that meant which I get because
everyone be so up in arms if he did stop
it but [ __ ] many time those two it was
like I think it was two or three at
least three three three to be fair
Thor hard and I liked anyway like like
he was done and he down like that I'm
done done I I don't like seeing that
[ __ ] is rough and and and and why isn't
there a standing eight count why can't
why can't if you wait like like I don't
have it it's all happening so quickly so
I know you can't it's actually safe or
not to have a statement account
why because so let's say let's say that
eight counts oh I hit you yet can cus
you go down and you can kind of stumble
back to your feet and then you make the
count you know I put you back out there
we know for sure you have brain trauma
you ain't as tough as you say no you're
done yeah but if but listen boxers all
time ago you good you walk towards me
they're good they're not good the brain
has suffered trauma I got well then I
put you back out there you get more
traumas bring in MMA I brought you on
top a few rabbit punch that stop it but
what about more brain Trump what about
like it was like there was one fight
who's the guys from Pittsburgh you have
the blonde hair bleached hair Kasich yes
there was one fight he was he had this
is years ago I mean it was a [ __ ]
bloodbath yeah and they were all tangled
up for a long time whose elbow to
hitting him blood spilling
you know they were it was a lot of it
was on the ground and I'm like this guy
could be dying underneath here so from
like blood loss just
from whatever yeah and they eventually
Kasich won but I was like why don't you
to a standing eight count to see if the
guys [ __ ] like the check but I'm not
tapping out you guys don't tap out
unless you've got a chocolate check
though but you know you can't let's just
not the rules see what did you look at
also a terminators pay-per-view so they
so three million no wind bus three
million 80s two billion that's a joke
hey but the next big yeah that's rough
then that's three million eight got two
million and then you got taxes you got
to pay your corner yeah your camp plate
whole training camp I got to pay your
sparring partners that you're going to
exploit to shout out to Conor McGregor
mmm hey go to that go to the mask Oregon
card in November that's that's the next
big card if it comes to fruition there's
some that's the next huge huge fight
because they think hopefully uh you have
Holly verse cyborg on their dare
fighting there they both want the fight
who's gonna win that cyborg and what
kind of fashion punch in the face
early hard uh not to Holly's my girl but
I wanted to that ass I like them both
sigh boards outside word I had on the
show she's great she's cool she's cool
as well where's she from Brazil she's a
beef and what about my girl that kicked
Ron his ass which one
um oh the champ where she at
oh she chipped she got a she got ill so
she's alright right man who this was
supposed to fight Shevchenko if she got
ill so their fight mask we're done I
think right or they fighting in Edmonton
so so if they're paying the men two
million dollars and 3-mile knows how
much exploitation is going on the female
fighters they're getting [ __ ] nothing
unless your name Ronda Rousey great
white house news done yeah so I mean the
listen they're painting what you're
worth is as far as marketability lives
so like those galaxies and punk unless
zero fights goes in there makes you know
whatever two million because he's a
paper you draw you're only getting paid
if your pay-per-view draw is in cyborg
go to Wikipedia on that as a habit won't
the fans watch whatever they put up
there's you there's
as you have seen 2096 they also it's not
true no so unless it starred Riven the
numbers don't correlate it's the same
with so I was having this argument with
Julio Chavez on ESPN he was saying that
you know in boxing it's bigger because
this Canelo and his numbers I went whoa
no no because your best boxers triple G
probably and he pulls in 200-300
max pay-per-views three to three hundred
thousand max so but the bigger stars
Canelo so for us like if it's Conor Diaz
any of these guys they're great but
Mighty Mouse might be the but you know
some say the best I got it's like a
hundred thousand I got let's all star
driven I got sport just dropped Stargell
any sports
yeah but the Dolphins has no stars the
Cowboys are pulling right I got you I
might not be as good but they're pulling
[ __ ] ready I got you I got you like
gold states and happen to be the best
team but they also have the best players
right who you want to watch I may have
bran polls right oh right like tiwa the
spurred Kawhi Leonard great team no one
tunes indle no not wise as great as he
is he's just so under the radar in terms
of he's just there to play ball but
we'll watch Houston right you know I'm
saying I got to miss all-star driven
it's way the world works so that they
don't have it all on there so I guess
the only one that there a new one that
they're targeting is yenge a check
against namajunas yes they're strongly
tied up the rumors I heard on the car
discard insane but that's the next big
one
GSP Bisbing GSP he's washed up though
right
he's been help for four years that that
fight why is he fighting he didn't make
any money he made decent Moses nicknamed
Captain America well off record most
people call him brush Georgia brush st.
Pierre but towards Enders crews like
George kind of let's wait it was in
Captain America they called as America
okay so he's finding lands in America
he's fighting for money yes he's just
doing it for the payday huh
because there's these nice prime not
gonna be what he used to be he's been
knocked out some say he's the best of
all time who cares
I know so you wanna Kobe Bryant it was
Michael Jordan and at certain points
over but Kobe's don't do three four fine
we know Kobe Bryant is any money now we
know we ain't doing it for money now
he's selling it yeah mama
yeah with GSP out it's tricky man I is
playing
is from what I hear is to fight Michael
Bisbing win that vacate the belt and
then hopefully get a mega fight with
Conor McGregor at 55 just saying okay
would you watch it it depends on that
this flight fight goes right
everything's up in the air with this boy
playing I can't wait for it to be over
but see this like you take a bath after
those those uh press conferences like
how did you feel like you're watching
some sort of smut film or like a
low-grade porno like you were right
there did you like I lost a bad and like
put a little bleach in it just to like
get the idol of Zin and I loved it you
know you know who impressed me the most
outside newcomers can be the Beast I was
so impressed with Floyd Mayweather how
just the way he runs it like a business
and he had his hands and everything and
he talked to him he's articulate and
he's like you can see he runs everything
here's his hand in everything that
everything he ain't a dummy he are from
it and what do you think I was like my
brother loves Floyd like yours roots
well your brother who never sends me
gear what's his [ __ ] name Jay Jay you
[ __ ] let's call him out again Jay Schwab
you you got your [ __ ] t-shirt rounded
Jay go [ __ ] yourself Jake nobody ever
done this show I'm a three-time guest of
the year can he'll [ __ ] water can't
get a [ __ ] water
look at that thing they're no [ __ ]
freaky sure Jane god damn it it's
ridiculous I'm not no [ __ ] UFC
fighter jail [ __ ] and walk off right now
the edge and Jay likes play hoops too
Jay I know you wanna you like to you
think you sitting courtside through and
you think you're gonna meet the [ __ ]
big three courtside you [ __ ]
you're gonna be getting me popcorn you
little prick August 26 you [ __ ] is Jay
gonna be there you might even [ __ ]
intern that day you [ __ ] you getting the
churl yeah you're yet your bed is this
you and [ __ ] Jay come clean miles
that way you get out of there in two
hours I don't want to see your [ __ ]
faces more than two hours Mayweather
wins you and Jay show up you where I am
Rappaport stereo podcast GG earns you
are my loan that last shirt you gave me
the gringo and opening Ringo mandingo I
love that shirt not the gringo sing the
gringo mandingo I'll say it how shirt
sales goes hey gringo mandingo Ringo
Mandy your [ __ ]
one good they should be there going good
you are lower manager now you don't pick
a lane you do basketball baseball
basketball fantasy football's you're so
full football I'm a fan of MMA I'm not
an expo going to I get your on bars um
our soil love bar stool can I tell you
about can I tell you about I want to
come back October 31st Simon and
Schuster
I wrote a book it's a [ __ ] talking
extravaganza the name of the book is
this book has Bulls the cover school is
sports rants from the MVP of talking
trash I love it all sports all [ __ ]
talking what's this what's the book
about like they just give me the gist of
it I'll give you a couple of chapters 23
reasons why you'll never be like Mike
LeBron James you said a little bit
what's your problem of a bran 20 you'll
read it in the book fun of mothers uh-uh
the whitewash the great white hopeful a
story of Ronda Rousey oh wow um I have a
cello made with a chapter great in the
ring shitty life haha I got my uh a
story when I was young when I fell in
love with Mary Lou Retton the gymnast
loved it um [ __ ] Question Time with
Bill Belichick you know he never answers
questions does the same thing you over
no I'm gonna get the NFL laminate and
imagined if I got if I was at the
presser Liz it's all Isis it in and it's
a lot of fun it's good this book has
balls sports rants from the MVP of
talking trash October 31st which you can
pre-order net weren't you with your
[ __ ] phone out let's whip it out
we're gonna pre-order a copy this book
has balls calm all right pre-order to
put the cutting door right now bro this
book has balls calm I'm [ __ ] proud of
[ __ ] of it this book go to Amazon while
so it's not a website it's a website Oh
second all right
this book has balls you can bring it
right here right Jen the book on tape is
fantastic you like the cover look there
are by dr. J I got the Jewish stars
instead of the converse tile now on the
commas you worked out for that shot how
do I look
why don't you why don't you want a copy
for you in for Jay we're doing right I'm
sorry
we're going to three of them chin or
that barely loud yet through yet three
orders right now there you go me home
pre-sales what you're getting come back
though on a sober just for that
traditional that for sure
bombs I'm trying to do my [ __ ] man I'm
having a good time yeah I love seeing
him in you killing it
let's do some current events man before
his [ __ ] voice goes up sounds good
how you take you to how long was that
hole a year lab a year here it's it's
it's some work like I've had people
operate do books I'm like well what's
the commitment it's it's work you got to
want to do it and and and the thing
about writing I learned is you've got to
have a point of view and you got to
trust it and and and it and your voice
isn't just you're talking voice it's not
just your [ __ ] talking boys because when
you should talk to you you could go
forward you double back then I could
talk about your shoes all day I talked
about him at the beginning I talked
about them now I could say your shoes
look like [ __ ]
look at how much they are you measure oh
my god oh my god like you shouldn't be
betting that kind of money because
you're gonna lose it all on this counter
fight and you're gonna have a pair of
[ __ ] cowboy boots that you pay for
how much you a $1100 those things are
not to how much then I achieve
how much do you waste on these [ __ ] up
cowboy boots with heels
who wears shoes with heels in 2007
single arrived these are [ __ ] damn
every Rod Stewart would wear these
[ __ ] [ __ ] in his prime Rod Stewart
wear wear those in the do you think I'm
ever going would [ __ ] no he wouldn't
waited boy where this David Rowling
would say those are strong could fit on
me don't take a pig for your girl and
say hey what do you think is booted it
oh my god [ __ ] love them get them
please here did you want some convinced
to okay this is absolutely and you come
in with those you come in with those
anything about your simple I got nothing
to prove right all right little sad but
verse one on the set of Deadpool to a
stunt motorcycle driver she died and
it's actually a girl Kendall here in
Manhattan and she flew off and crash
into like a windowpane zenn-la looks
like Ellie or Vancouver but yeah so it's
a girls driver that's sauce tomato that
passed away Ando and our drivers are
rough gig now we'll start the special
motorcycles in town has a boy's name is
Kenji was doing a think fast and furious
in one of those movies using the
Reverend he's in everything and he got
he's doing a getaway scene and hit a
pole that you're supposed to do he's a
concussion in coma for like 21 days
somebody that's crossed all taste in his
mouth still does it - that's it that's a
gnarly gig man who's Callan and either
one of those movies know he's doing
Goldberg okay another stunt thing I'm
sure you've seen this area Tom Cruise
jumping from a building to another
building and got injured for Mission
Impossible six he does all his own [ __ ]
[ __ ] that I didn't know that my
daughter's I have it - do your own
stunts anything my characters don't do
stunts
I don't play characters that that you
can better like stunt people
what's the Netflix show you got right
now a typical what's it about family
show about a family we have a kid with
autism good funny heartfelt fun show
it's good sense though you watch it with
your family it's good yeah your your uh
is it suits - uh your sons - too young
oh I'll watch it though watch it with
him like well he's like what are you
tearing up the house 17 months old this
[ __ ] [ __ ] up there's no whether he's
coming or going not he's just being
auteur yeah it's awesome yeah but it's
good I like it when you get your Tom
Cruise on and [ __ ] jump off they will
never hire me to jump just a video let
me see every little clip of it the
character that I would do would be boom
oh you can tell he actually hit the
building with his legs
boom yeah what he's a badass though
everyone I know that's worked with him
from director say he's like too bad his
French to shape and everything yeah they
say he covered Danny Lee so you got
[ __ ] up yeah he covers it you are
talking about detail dude they say
everything he's on that side type for
real come on he's on that full-blown
side tie slides on that Scientology I'm
on that [ __ ] full-on side of the
whole five five years ago you're telling
me if they Kayla was like a kid up the
career of Tom Cruise would be full [ __ ]
no we had a little blinking my eyes get
the [ __ ] out of here
you watch that Leah Remini short
Scientology yes she has another one
coming up does she
so Bella the Golden Snitch don't shut up
about it
like I got it I got it's over now all
right they suck but here's the thing now
this is back on a level of 17
hi its 2017 no it's fine enough for
Scientology does the internet but people
are still in it they're still in it
because they don't let them have
technology but there's no new [ __ ]
customers I don't agree with that I
don't think it's what it was I guarantee
it though the admissions low I agree
let's put out part of it is you can say
like her you can't make that religion
now just build on what the [ __ ] religion
it's a religion I know that's a [ __ ]
that's a big I make in any religion
right now anything think of it even old
religion you if you pitch Christianity
right now to the world to go what thou
[ __ ] I'm gonna follow a book what he
died and came back kids I [ __ ] in my
face I agree the trade I agree but with
Scientology my quote what the [ __ ] that
guy was a genius evil genius put a
[ __ ] his name L hub Elrond l ron
Hubbard yep what else you got chin I get
it the [ __ ] outta here man oh [ __ ] out
of here
uh how about okay so this dude like a
week ago
oh yeah I was like arrested for pushing
a girl in front of a bus in London it
looked like she's trying to trip him the
way yeah so that's you know what look
what look where they're jogging on the
side of a freeway but to bolt them but
he's like a rider like you're not Tom
Cruise [ __ ] I agree you're not
getting [ __ ] from Mission Impossible 9 I
agree but for her let's stay away from
the road buddy right being but homewards
you could just go around like there's a
lot of rain bolt I agree when they got
the wrong guy
they actually accidentally arrested a 41
year old millionaire who was able to
prove that he was not an attention to
[ __ ] up yeah and now they're you they're
back on the hunt for the actual pusher
woo
so how about your boys the real Captain
America tweeted that and goes let's
catch this guy and the next day someone
got him I mean what do you think of all
what catches guy what do you think
Hollywood tough guys like myself uh when
he really could kick ass you don't think
about fighting right now never I'd ever
do like it sound like you
to fight anybody ever ever I hate being
big I hate I don't like that acting
class and but but do you have people
real tough guys on that tough or talked
about it like if you like if we met and
starts on about the street fights you've
been in I would zoom out right away
yeah well that's ridiculous if you guys
do it do they want to do with you yeah
oh if they don't know me because it does
trying to prove their toughness no but
if they do know you like don't they want
to be like why you so yeah I did karate
in seventh grade on all-time all-time
and you're like no you know what I think
now I wiped my ass this morning too
now I'm dealing with people trying to
always trying to bet me with the Conor
Mayweather thing everyone everywhere I
go hey it'll be over soon do you want it
to be over
I'm excited for it to work every time
once it's over it'd be fun I like I just
want I want to get to the fighter and
then that's it I want to be done but
what else is there to do right now
sports well then we got football then
the triple G fight though there's always
more I'm just an NBA during this time I
agree time I agree it's perfect - I
agree I agree now it's good but it's
[ __ ] booster like Jenna felt playoffs
end up come on right
you know no it's gonna work out good
what else you get Jim alright Amir Khan
officially apologized to Anthony Joshua
for accusing him of cheating with his
wife you hear about this I caught like a
week ago was it or two weeks ago yeah
like tomorrow I'm Eric on accused his
wife of cheating with Anthony Joshua and
in the video was so those like fake
screenshots he thought were real so he
said that oh yeah my wife and him are
cheating that he wants to get a divorce
turns out they were actually fake
screenshots and I think they're still
separating because of this so I don't go
to Twitter for ten but then yeah so
Joshua says you know apology accepted
it's all it's all under the under the
rug now yeah what else you got chin
implosion what do you want Rick players
in the hospital ya know from what I'm
wearing for they say common motors I
ain't no [ __ ] like wrestling or former
athletes when you get older [ __ ] happens
man Ric Flair huh hopefully I'm how old
is he 60 something would yeah hopefully
he's all right classic man that's what
happens though you know really get the
good good thanks Doug
that's
[ __ ] oak ragu slash prank three and a
half inches oh good good chance with us
good what else you got chamber god
states right let me [ __ ] fake the
news about Aamir Khan I'm sorry damn it
how about this last year the military
was actually opening enrollment to uh
for women for all military positions
right even the hardest ones like Navy
SEALs
yeah the very first woman to ever enter
it has dropped out now so she dropped
out somebody will make it you think as a
woman as a Navy SEAL I mean yeah I think
it'll happen I'm not an expert on what
it takes but how many how many other men
have dropped out while she dropped out
that's true that 75% of everyone that
gets involved I'm saying like if she can
do it let her do it I agree if they can
do it do it it's gonna be tough
and I'm all about women's right and
stuff like that there are certain
athletic endeavors a great job that men
do better it's not a show Grenadier and
wronger than women physically that
doesn't mean I could fight cyborg yes so
beat me up
don't get [ __ ] crazy but in general
like that whole thing with Serena and
John macro people were so offended that
macro said that she couldn't you know
she'd be ten thousandth or whatever it's
[ __ ] true and I'm the biggest Serena
family - I love Serena but it's like you
know it's just men and women were just
different and not the same no we're not
you know these [ __ ] hipsters with her
you know like we were all the same the
gentler genderless no we're not because
if I pull this loaf out first are you
gonna be shocked
okay good light high low oh the [ __ ]
gringo mandingo we're talking right here
I thought oh now it's lipase like that
so what yeah I'm kind of Dutch we'll
make you even more mesmerizer all right
but be like we should celebrate our
differences and accept it like we want
to be genderless I know but I can sure I
do we only had a minor [ __ ] [ __ ]
then then didn't come talk to me I don't
get the big deal like with with women
not being Navy SEALs okay cool that's
not for you men can't do a lot of [ __ ]
women can do who gives a [ __ ] a lot
actually comes the physical attributes
men are just better stronger say
stronger will the faster stronger but
you're seeing better see I'm
trying to protect you from the [ __ ]
I'm trying to have this I'm Linda Felina
[ __ ] done up yes just Arlena [ __ ]
done I'm saying when it comes to Navy
SEALs the guiltiest white person on the
planet do you know anybody else is more
white guilt and Lena Dunham that should
be the Clippers you know any white
person on the planet Earth with more
white guilt than Lena [ __ ] dumb
Dunham the woman who had a show on the
air for six years great girl she had a
show any other school girls that took
place in Brooklyn
with no black people in it this is the
guiltiest white lady in the world you
know her and she blocked you on lock me
up
why don't you block you I'm so hard in
the pain Anna not naive but but just
like in that kind of way I don't like
talk about like no you know like looks
or anything like that way that's not
that's not my thing
yeah it's just like she liked the voices
the fact that she she's anointed herself
the voice of her generation to me is you
can do better you can get a better voice
here there's better voices you know I'm
surprised by and I saw your rant honest
at those brilliant but those white
supremacists and neo-nazis I simply
don't go don't go call night I can't
believe that [ __ ] still exists I was
like what the [ __ ] and I'm like if you
really want to get it poppin wired like
if you want to get it poppin why are you
doing out there go in it you know where
to find the wall let me now go into
Brooklyn new Newport News they were down
to Virginia go around you know let me
know how it works out for you see how
that works out there with that Bush and
didn't go in Atlanta with their [ __ ]
skinny jeans like just like the ones
that that were on camera like there was
it like a cup of them what there's one
guy with sunglasses a blind neo-nazi
he's up there doing this [ __ ] like blind
what the hell you know they covering his
[ __ ] finger you know but like they
like where are these guys during the
daytime like we pull their Instagram
like I want to go see him like yeah
what's really good my man yeah I know
doing his Heil Trump [ __ ] I mean Trump
you know is a real [ __ ] boy I'm Jewish
you know a real [ __ ] boy is Jared
Kushner he's an Orthodox Jew Sunday
dinner with Donald Trump you're not
getting into a fight with your father a
little shame on you you [ __ ] panty
wearing pampering taking [ __ ]
Jared Kushner is a [ __ ]
made and he's a mother [ __ ] he's an
Orthodox Jew Jesus I guarantee you he
bleeds every month like a little [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he is a [ __ ] [ __ ] these people are
saying hail Trump and you say nothing
you have nothing to say about the year
in Orthodox Jew your father is of your
father laws are easy is the president
United States you got nothing to say
shame on you [ __ ] you dipped his
face
dumb [ __ ] I can't stand that
[ __ ] that's it good Jim you've
been here for at all what's up
you've been here for at all you're here
the whole show it's August it is you
want to give me the guests in your bell
now should I just come back in January
well help I have to get it made no it's
a little while okay I'm done it I'm
[ __ ] done done man look out of your
paint on homeboys everything I like imma
have you cool you know you're coming to
clean my house and I want it done by the
end of the month we're not like oh I'm
not like I'll just melt into all your
September I'll give you September I'll
give you some to pay I'll show ya let me
send your dick pigs get over your whole
thing watch the watch the smut off you
from that fight and then you're coming
to my crib you wheels are the same Jay
you and Jay you can do [ __ ] I want
you guys in Palma now I'm videotaping
holding up some pom-poms there to get
both of them [ __ ] I love it man
well the officer you can find you
[ __ ] all over big three Michael rap -
[ __ ] Pollyanna see football fantasy
football
this book has balls calm preorder 30 but
I'm going to come back here come back
we'll do that we'll do it with Brian
let's talk about your book critique it
you're the best brother any he'll talk
about like how he read it like Brian
cows would like probably the biggest
fake reader on the planet the biggest if
you name any books well I read that
[ __ ] he didn't read [ __ ] with it
with the he's got like a B D on steroid
monster I [ __ ] no a send down
reading here's ago I read that in The
Times and The Wall Street Journal
[ __ ] I saw the same tweet you
favorited it and this is regurgitated
Osaka regurgitate is like whole I read
OCS keynote what no you did it where's
the books you need to read share degrees
is [ __ ] scripts I
movie without a book in his house in
that room [ __ ] Andy Murray his own
scripts he shows up his [ __ ] learns
his lines it shows up there you're out
you're the best brother this is the
fighter in the rap we're out there guns
of fun